nationally with 67 days left in office
president trump greeted supporters
earlier today from his motorcade
they gathered to rally in the nation's
capital while the president who has made
unproven claims of voter fraud still has
not conceded the election
meantime president-elect joe biden is
working on a transition to the oval
office in january
cbs news correspondent michael george
has more
president trump delighted cheering
supporters with a drive-by at a
so-called
million mega march in washington d.c the
message of this event
is to demand transparency and to protect
election integrity
crowds backing the president also
gathered outside the u.s supreme court
where they were met by counter
protesters and his supporters took to
the streets of atlanta
as president trump still refuses to
admit election defeat
the government is restricting access and
funding to president-elect joe biden's
transition team
in a statement friday former trump white
house chief of staff john kelly said in
part
the delay in transitioning is an
increasing national security and health
crisis
the current administration does not have
to concede but it should do the right
thing
just in case the constitutional system
declares they lost
in a rose garden speech friday president
trump seemed to allude to
change ahead as he discussed the
coronavirus which is spiking
across the u.s this administration will
not be going to a lockdown hopefully
the whatever happens in the future who
knows which administration will be i
guess time will tell
in a tweet president-elect biden called
the federal response to the pandemic
woefully lacking and urged president
trump to do more to battle the virus now
on saturday biden took a break for a
bike ride with the next first lady dr
jill biden near their delaware beach
house michael george cbs news